on va on se dirige vers ce que dit
monsieur tôt c'est un confinement moi je
pense général après c'est que de
suppositions
bien entendu ces voix là celui c'est ce
qu'il aurait fait en tant que
spécialiste de confinement général les
écoles toujours ouvert le problème qu'on
a on sait depuis le début c'est un mur
les ses codes ses réalisé au début
rappelez vous ils sont pas contagieux
les enfants mais c'est tout bas mais ils
sont su juste symptomatique
bien sûr inquiet ils ont certes pas mal
à terre puis les jeunes mouatassim tome
donc les enfants pouvaient pas voir
d'accord donc là on était ce monde et s
attendait où elle était c'est un jour
n'ont pas laissé toutes les semaines ça
servira à quoi à rien ça c'est de la
communication qui nuit en fête à la
santé publique et à la lutte contre ce
qu vide nos origines
mais je voudrais dire autre chose quand
même il y a un poids déterminant si
aujourd'hui nous utilisons l'occasion de
mettre en place une vraie politique
sanitaire consultés sur des fondements
de fondamentaux qu'ils soient même
légaux parce que le gros souci avec elle
est aujourd'hui on parle par exemple on
a décidé que 400 c'était le taux oui
c'est ce qu'il a dit mais bridge à
castanet malheureusement c'est utiliser
mon juridique
pourquoi il est d'une importance
capitale ça permettait si on avait
connaissance au niveau légal de cinq
critères d'objectivité des situations et
de les rendre le cas deschamps
compréhensible le problème
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans des à
courre permanent nous sommes des à-coups
permanent nous avons une situation de
détresse détresse des français
nous avons des enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont mal nous avons
des jeunes étudiants qui ont des dépôts
étaient suspects dont 12 ans je me
permets de le rappeler est ce
qu'aujourd'hui quand le faisait la
république à la 48e minute de son
interview du 14 juillet a dit je ne
confierai plus le peuple français
parce que confiné c'est un massacre
mental et il l'a dit il n'a pas utilisé
le mot massacre ce manque est nommé mais
c'était il était conscient de la
détresse qu'il engendre c'est rien n'a
été fait répond bien fait les choses
ça je crois que d'auteurs ça serait bien
que l'on puisse vraiment dire mes forces
que nous sommes dans une situation
d'échec d'une année de politique
intérieure le dr
donc pour revenir parce que c'est vrai
que c'est ça qui intéresse vraiment
aussi les français c'est très bien ce
qu'a dit aussi m bryza donc on se dirige
vers une annonce quoi demain ils vont
dire quoi ils vont dire confinement
général à votre avis et vos débuts comme
os à chaud on attend la fumée blanche
qui sort mais qui pourrait penser que
c'est pas confiné ce week-end là je
comprends rien ça veut dire que alors
dans ces cas-là on décide très
clairement depuis prendre des genres et
à basse et ça s'est replacé les chefs de
service où il n'y a pas à aujourd'hui
qui gère un jeu par dessus sur le
terrain je suis un pas ce qu'ils
racontent ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît laissez nous respirer
parce que les soignants là ils sont 20 c
et on a plus de lait et j'ai donc
confinement donc semaine c'est ce qu'on
dit de payer combien de fois trois
semaines n'a pas trahi mais vrai ces
trois semaines lui on va attendre plus
on va jouer comme ça au petit joueur
plus ça va être long c'est ça vous fait
plus le début donc trois semaines trois
semaines penser que ça peut suffire et
comment je peux vous dire ça je vais pas
vous dire trois semaines en fait on va
voir les chiffres c'est clair c'est sa
c6
s'il faut quatre semaines s'il faut deux
semaines je sais pas quoi regarder quoi
arrêtons de dire oui aux joueurs ils ont
en plus des semis confinement bientôt ça
va être à 17 heures à 16 heures savait
pas qu'il y ait des soir c'est fini on a
voulu faire du stop and go ça n'a pas
marché
maintenant il est temps d'être efficace